[Music]
my girlfriend woke me up in the middle
of the night to check out a noise don't
do that I don't want to get up and if
it's a noise out there
let it be out there nothing good is
happening in the middle of the night
I know it's not gonna be me you're awake
you check it out I'm scared too
oh but because I'm the man I just got to
be out ready to go out there and murder
at any point in time that's not fair I
don't wake her up for her chores
I don't just shake her awake honey we're
out of olive oils I don't do that but
I'm the guy so I got to be able to
easily murder at any point in time not
fair at all all day men are supposed to
be in touch with their emotions but at
night I have to sleep like a baby and
then be able to be a primal rage monster
at any moment it's the middle of the
night my contacts are out I can't see I
got half a boner what am I gonna do best
thing I'm gonna do is just scare him
away
just scat scat get out of here don't
look down there just leave the noise is
never a good surprise I'm not just gonna
walk out into my kitchen and be like
whoa look an ice cream cake honey come
quick there's a quinceanera in the
kitchen then I show up I got half a
boner everyone's upset and now I'm not
allowed within a hundred feet of my own
kitchen is that what you want
Hey I heard something go check it out
well it's nothing nope just an Amazon
box
well it's Jordan from work I'm on the
phone anyways it's crazy that Marvel has
a movie called Captain Moore no god I'm
like a Comedy Central no that's a
raccoon it's just a dog doing a podcast
but it's just a Getty image it's just us
from the future
now the raccoon is back in he's from the
future I'm going to bed
look I'm all for being a protector but
not in the middle of the night just let
him take the TV I want a new one anyway
let the house burn down let's accept
death together we're sleeping together
we should be ready for this to society's
upset the boys don't express their
emotions well you know what bugs are
icky noises are loud and I'm sleeping
you deal with it and then I'll go to
therapy and address these issues
basically what I'm saying is I need a
boyfriend just a man that sleeps in a
chair all night with a bat and makes me
feel safe you know he's nice to me he
takes care of me and I come on his
birthday once a year
good night hey now it's time for the
YouTube shout-out this one comes from oh
my brother yesterday on the show Jordan
was talking about an orgy and his
experience in one and my brother wrote I
think of you pause it at 1:22 you can
see the exact moment where Ryan
non-verbally tells our mother to stop
watching the show I thought it was like
telling people like guys what is going
on this is crazy and then everyone was
like like pee everyone talk to
individuals I don't know this was crazy
and then I would see them in the the
thing that's exactly what I was doing
but I'm not gonna do it today I want you
to like comment subscribe and make sure
to watch our other show on Twitter extra
damn day
thank you for watching folks
[Music]